okay let's see if we can just check in
um with with a couple more people right
i mean there there's just so much action
happening right now
let's speak to brian from florida brian
you're on the air brian with a why
importantly can you hear me yes i can
all right cool thank you and uh yeah
brian with the y
is very important uh uh big fan of your
show
i just have a question uh like uh
why so um why are you still covering
trump
sorry why am i still covering trump
yeah i mean he's not the president
anymore i get that he has a
a a base but uh
yeah i mean so listen i mean i've i have
a clip out about this already
we're really mostly not covering trump i
think this week out of about 50 stories
we do
i think like two or three are trump
related um so we're really
not but it you know we to pretend that
the tr the republican party is no longer
trumpian
would be delusional i would be doing you
a disservice
they just voted to expel this cheney
it's uh you know this is a trumpian
republican party so to some degree i
have to keep covering it yeah
for sure but um there are
tons of stuff going on right now there's
some great stuff going on well that's
why again out of 50 stories this week i
think two or three had to do with trump
cool okay well maybe i just um i i watch
it you know
uh fairly regularly whenever i whenever
i can i just put it that way
yeah and i still still a huge you know a
big fan of your uh
of your of your channel i just think
it's not just you
you know what i'm saying and i you know
you haven't been highlighting it but a
lot of
um left wing i guess you could label it
as that
uh they still talk about trump and um
the the minute he got uh the minute joe
biden got inaugurated
it was such a big uh relief and i'm you
know not to get into that but it just
seemed like
people would just fall back on on trump
and i still hear a lot of um
a lot of left people still talk about
him
yeah i mean again i think it's
appropriate because until the
the republican party still seems to be
the party of trump
and if that's the case it's it's hard
not to talk about him
uh to some degree but uh i agree with
you that you know making
making it or anything the sole focus uh
when so many things are going on doesn't
make a lot of sense
even naming i mean it's labeled the
trump i mean that's just
it's just so many things that gives
power to his the the like the entity of
trump
like it's a trump base yeah i don't know
i i i should be rebranded
i don't know i mean but the thing is if
it's if it's still the party of trump if
70
of the party still thinks trump won if
two-thirds of the party would follow
trump if he left the republican party
it's not up to us to start calling it
something else when
if and when the republican party stops
being the party of trump i'll stop
saying
it you know me me using different
language isn't actually going to change
anything it's just not going to
accurately reflect reality
i can't do that to my audience yeah for
sure
that's it man that's all right are we so
we're still we're still on good terms
right
brian oh yeah okay good all right
all right good thanks for the call i
appreciate it yeah all right take care
uh there's brian from florida uh love
brian from florida great call
all right thank you to everybody that
called in there are always more calls to
take but at some point it must end
and we will take calls again very soon